it'll be carlos martinez on the mound
for st
louis he is three and nine and the
cardinals need
ricky and keel they need carlos martinez
to be good tonight
win a series the one-two pitch lined
caught and double play that will help
doubles off rojas at first the liner
into the glove of sosa over to goldie
and a double play to end the top of the
first cardinals coming up in the bottom
half and there's no score for your
d-back starter tonight the left-hander
caleb smith
earlier this month reclaimed his
starting spot after two months in the
bullpen and he has given the d back some
much needed stability that rotation he
really has and you have to tip your cap
to caleb smith he
found himself in the bullpen after that
shaky start against san diego to start
this season he went down to the pen and
didn't mope didn't pout he went out
there and got out earned his way back
into that rotation and he's taking full
advantage of it
the o2 pitch coming from smith
this this one to deep left center field
reddick is out there
and he's got it at the gap here's a
pitch to the 22 year old carlson and
they scround ball back to them on
smith has got it and fires the first
plenty of time out number two
smith ready checks the two base runs
popped him up
nick ahmed drifting into foul ground and
caleb smith strands those
pair of two out walks no score after
work when you struggle against the
pitcher it's always owen two and that's
what it is to ahmed right now he's
hitting 223.
there's a swing and a miss first
strikeout for
carlos martinez with the pitcher coming
up great slider from carlos right there
for strike three and what a way to start
the third
inning one-two pitch is a called strike
three
back-to-back strikeouts for carlos
martinez both of them on sliders
and that pitch has been sharp here this
inning so caught looking as caleb smith
and back to the top of the order in josh
rojas who walked in the first
swang and a miss he strikes out the side
here in the third inning
three strikeouts in this game and all in
the third
ahmed smith rojas and there's no score
44 pitches now for smith as he works in
the bottom of the third inning
3-2 to admin right there with calls
strike three third strikeout for caleb
another pitch to goldschmidt on a count
of one and two
fastball by him four strikeouts for
caleb smith
two one and two out for tyler o'neill
called strike three three strikeouts in
the inning for caleb smith
five in the ball game i don't think
martinez one time is called off yada or
molina they've been on
same page from the onset tonight
and he has struck out four in a row
something about the rhythm those two are
in right now
carlos right here throwing a back door
slider gets pavemen smith looking in the
pits before the changeup was
outstanding pitch what i love is the
pace that he's at
he is a dangerous batter the 1-2
delivery swing at a miss that is
five strikeouts in a row for carlos
martinez
watch the bottom foul out of this slider
great pitch
very efficient to get to the 50 pitch
mark and the
2-1 peralta breaks his bat fly ball
shallow right and carlos martinez
is sharp tonight eight in a row no score
carlos does not want to lose this batter
right here
nothing nothing game runners at first
and third two outs the pitcher up
who's over ten with ten strikeouts now
three and two and over at first
stephen vogt will be running chopped
towards third
orinato will glove and makes the play
carlos made the pitch he needed to leave
two men on
and halfway through the game at busch
stadium it's the cardinals nothing the
diamondbacks nothing
orinato is walked in singled and then
base hit will give the criminals a lead
here in the home half of the fifth
2-2 pitch arenado hits it down the
left-hand line
hooking god it's off the foul pole
an absolute rocket and a scream
from nolan two-nothing cardinals
well arenado looking fastball or
something straight
gets one up in the zone they've been
trying to beat him up there to hold it
back
and hits a laser down the left field
line
give the cardinals a 2-0 lead the camera
of tony angelus into your living room
i got it pretty good camera work right
there careful with this
guy paving smith one ball and no strikes
there's a little tap off the end of the
bat arnotto bare handed
oh what a play nolan orinato
remarkable play from the cardinal third
baseman
holy smokes that looks like a video game
play
pavon smith hits it off the end of the
bat nolan aronado understand
he's got speed two bear hands it somehow
gets rid of it quick enough to get
pavemen at first base
wow in disbelief that was
awesome rojas at second now one out for
escobar who's over two
escobar sends one down the line in right
he drops in rojas coming around he will
score eduardo escobar
gets the diamondbacks on the board all
right that's a start halfway there
edwardo didn't get all of this one
little breaking ball that worked off the
inside corner of the plate but he got
enough of it
just down near the trademark little
floating line drive down the right field
line to play josh rohawks runners off of
the pitch on three and two you have good
speed at sosa
carpenter will get a nice jump in first
base they'll play behind him with a
left-handed batter
and two runners on there they go and
edmond base head into right
social will score carpenter to third
a two out rally for the cardinals here
in the bottom of the sixth
tommy edmond a two-hit knight and it's
three to one
great to see tommy getting in on the
action as you mentioned two
hit night fastball out over pulls it
through the hole for an
rbi cardinals could use that insurance
run that was huge
and maybe he's going to be on an upward
trajectory the cardinals
of course need tommy edmond to be a part
of this offense
if it's going to be uh what they want it
to be and this is cabrera loads the
bases so they'll go to andrew miller all
to the bullpen base is full of d-backs
and two outs
pavemen smith is the scheduled hitter
heath of course here represents what
would be the tying run with two outs
he walked in a run it's three to two
third walk in the inning
drawn by a diamondbacks hitter three and
two
and the diamondbacks down to their final
strike here 32 pitches the most that
reyes has thrown the ball game this year
and he wants to end it right here
can he do it 3-2 pitch swung on and
missed
reyes gets the final six outs and the
cardinals hold on for a 3-2 win and a
series win against the diamondbacks and
they'll look for a sweep tomorrow